I'm Steve Grove from the OECD in Paris
I'd like to talk a little bit about what
some of the challenges are that we see
in ASEAN which include respect to
development your assemble a couple of
challenges that we see in Oceania and in
Asia more broadly as income tu quoque
inequality on education and on fun
governance and so I think these are the
ways that these countries can begin to
address some of the challenges they face
and development first on income
inequality we need to see a better
distribution of growth in these
countries that can be achieved through
more investments in education that can
be achieved and more accountable
approaches to government where
governments are accountable to their
people for their populace and not
necessarily to outside stakeholders so
that's what I would recommend thinking
about some of the challenges we will see
this first better investment in
education all the way from primary
education all the way up through
tertiary education with a good big
strong focus on primary and secondary
education secondly on income inequality
this is going to be a real break on
growth in the region if we don't address
this problem it's going to go it's going
to you will find yourself very easily in
the Latin America's traffic when we
don't see growth beyond a certain level
has to be real challenge for ASEAN this
can be real challenge for Asian general
if that's not addressed and one way in
the third way that we can address that
is by beginning to look a little more
more seriously on my governments that
are accountable to the people through
their populace and to their citizens